en Israel más de 6 millones de personas
votan en la quinta elección legislativa
del año 2019 en la que 39 partidos están
en disputa pero donde la decisión se
reduce en dos bandos por un lado el de
benjamina tan Yahoo juzgado por
corrupción y por otro lado la debilitada
coalición centrista al actual al Primer
Ministro Yahir lapid nosotros saludamos
a Gabriel ventasgal él es analista
político especializado en medio oriente
Gabriel Gracias por estar con nosotros o
buena mañana ya de martes Cuál es la
situación política de Israel porque
tanta traba Porque tanto bloqueo digamos
y porque hace ya desde más de tres años
no hay un gobierno pues es corriente que
realmente se enfoque en la población en
solucionarle los problemas a las
personas y no solucionar los problemas
internos políticos
porque el mapa político A diferencia de
ser un mapa político que se centra en la
discusión ideológica se centra en la
figura de netaniaus están entre los
partidos que apoyan la netaniado y los
que están en contra aunque sean partidos
nacionalistas O sea no se respeta la
ideología si no se ha transformado en
una brecha en la persona del Primer
Ministro anterior
porque la figura de netanyahu es tan
fuerte digamos es tan importante en
Israel sobre todo en este momento
podríamos estar al frente de un
inminente de regreso de Benjamín
netanyahu además digamos que parece que
todos los casos de corrupción no le han
servido en su contra no
tres cosas diferentes la primera que los
casos de corrupción desde el punto de
vista legal son más endebles de lo que
aparentaban
lo segundo es que netaníau tiene
acumulado 15 años de Primer Ministro y
además es una persona que tiene mucho
carisma y conocimiento acumulado y por
último el que tiene mayor posibilidad
hoy en día de formar gobierno es netanía
Aún si consigue 61 de los 120 escaños
del parlamento
existe una posibilidad que eso ocurra
pero la posibilidad alternativa no es un
gobierno de Centro izquierda es que
vayamos a sexta selecciones
A qué te refieres Gabriela con que estos
procesos de corrupción de neta Yahoo Son
son endebles son son frágiles no son
fácil de probar Que realmente pasa en
esos casos entonces
es que en el caso de corrupción en su
contra lo acusaban de a haber sido
favorecido por un medio de comunicación
a cambio de haber ayudado
regulatoriamente al dueño de una empresa
de teléfonos que la también el dueño de
la medio de comunicación
en la defensa Ha logrado demostrar que
no hay tal manipulación de los de los
beneficios que le dieron al dueño de la
empresa telefónica y que tampoco recibió
demasiada cobertura positiva y es por
eso que es probable que ese caso de
corrupción específico caiga
Cuáles son las posibles coaliciones que
se pudieran formar
en tu opinión me dices que lo más
probable es que realmente si se vayan a
estas sextas elecciones estamos más
cerca de una sexta elección que de una
coalición de gobierno en este momento de
la actualidad política y israelí
probabilidad 1
netanía un consigue 61 diputados Y eso
es posible y la coalición la conforma
con la extrema derecha y con los
partidos ortodoxo judíos probabilidad 2
logra convencer a benigans un partido de
centro para que se una en un gobierno de
rotación
probabilidad 3 vamos a ver estas
elecciones qué pasa con el actual
gobierno de Yair lapid Porque tan
debilitada esta Alianza porque realmente
no digamos no funcionó y no sé
fortaleció para poder gobernar Israel
porque lo único que unía esta Alianza
era estar en contra de letaniaus y una
alianza si puede funcionar siempre y
cuando no existan problemas cuando
existen problemas re flotan los temas
ideológicos hablemos ahora de un
personaje clave que ha surgido en estas
quintas elecciones y de los cuales
podría ayudar digamos en esta coalición
fuerte de netanyahu en el caso de ganar
estas quintas elecciones y Tamara
bengavir Porque tan importante y como
pueden detallado formar una coalición
con el para poder gobernar que tanto
influencia tiene y Tamara digamos en la
política de Israel
Mira es un fenómeno digno de analizar y
de estudiar y preocupante porque estamos
hablando de una persona que Durante los
días del asesinato de ravin apoyaba la
violencia contra el Primer Ministro que
colgó en su casa un póster de un asesino
que mató a musulmanes inocentes en la
cueva de los patriarcas en hebrón Y que
además se representa un partido que
somófobo ahora este partido es
preocupante porque capta un montón de
votos de excepción de un montón de
personas que encuentran que él es la
esperanza políticamente incorrecta un
estilo Donald Trump extremizado
las críticas a sanitarias que tú te vas
a sentar con un hombre así lo que no
pueden explicar lo que lo critican le
tenía O es que ellos lo boicotean
Entonces no le queda otra alternativa
que buscar en su derecha un Aliado para
formar gobierno Yo sé que a lo mejor o
falta mucho pero pero digamos esta
importancia de la figura de itamar y
como dices tú un caso de análisis
podríamos ver en un futuro a lo mejor no
tan lejos a y tamar venga a vivir el
próximo Primer Ministro de israelí o no
llegaría hasta ese punto digamos hasta
donde se va a mantener dentro de la
política de Israel
Mira para hacer Primer Ministro de
Israel Tú tienes que ser izquierdista
dentro de la derecha
y tienes que ser derechista dentro de la
izquierda
en este caso el tamal cumplir es
derechista dentro de la derecha por lo
tanto sus posibilidades de lograr formar
gobiernos o sea ministros son menores
ahora Gabriel le quiero hablar también
de algo importante Esta última escalada
de la atención entre las fuerzas
israeías y los territorios o palestinos
que pues evidentemente le hemos venido
informando estas últimas semanas no esto
también como ha influido Sí sí o no
digamos en esta en estas quintas
elecciones en esta inestabilidad
política del gobierno los judíos
esperaban A lo mejor otro comportamiento
el gobierno o sea que realmente ha
aportado esto para la inestabilidad
política y también en estas en estas
quintas elecciones y podemos ver un
reflejo de esto en las urnas
totalmente y una de las respuestas la
dimos antes los que están sufriendo
atentados o piensan que el gobierno no
ha sido suficientemente contundente
contra los que hacían atentados están
votando a
o sea él capta el voto decepción por la
situación política los atentados
terroristas De todas formas no creo que
cambie demasiado porque la gente no
habla específicamente de Eso le preocupa
más la situación económica la
importancia de cómo en la inflación está
afectando la economía local Y nuevamente
las figuras de netaníau en el centro y
su personalidad cuando vamos a poder ver
Gabriel el desarrollo digamos de estas
elecciones y hablar de una sexta
elección cuando podría ser ya sería el
año que viene y mientras tanto entonces
Yair la Pitt seguiría en el poder porque
evidentemente alguien tiene que estar no
al mando del país
bien desde el punto de vista práctico
hoy a las 10 de la noche se sabe los
votos a pie de urna y Dios te aconsejo
como colega periodista no anuncien
porque va a ser realmente voto a voto va
a definir porque como te dije al
principio lo que decir esta elección es
cinetaneal logra o no logra 61 bancadas
O sea que es tan estrecho el margen de
maniobra que es difícil anunciar a pie
de urna resultado final va a tardar dos
días más y durante ese periodo de tiempo
y a ir la pir va a ser ministro
temporario Hasta que el presidente del
Estado site a los partidos políticos y
le asigna durante 28 Días aquel
candidato a forma al gobierno la
posibilidad de conformar tal coalición